this is what justin trudeau is he is a
deeply dishonest basically soulless
soulless nothing he's not he's not
defending canada he's not defending the
people of canada he's just absolutely
awful so i've mentioned jordan peterson
a couple times here here's jordan
peterson justin trudeau how can
discourse
in a great democracy have become so
polarized
that jordan peterson and the prime
minister look at exactly the same set of
events
and come to opposite conclusions about
them well he's lying
and i'm not
so that's a big part of the
that's a big part of the issue i don't
believe
that he ever says a word that's true
from what i've been able to observe it's
all stage acting he's crafted a persona
he has a particular instrumental
goal in mind and everything is
subordinated to serve that
why what's the motivation
uh the same motivation that generally
that's generally typical of people who
are narcissistic
which is to
uh be accredited with moral virtue in
the absence of the work necessary to
actually attain it
ain't it the truth ain't the truth and
don't we have way
too many people in our political
establishment our media establishment
that are doing the exact same thing they
are never telling you the truth they are
never even trying to find the truth
they're not even going directionally
towards the truth they are endlessly
doing everything for
political goals so what is this what is
this really about now think about it
there's a horrific horrific shooting in
uvalde texas last week okay
19 kids killed some teachers i mean the
story is still unfolding it sounds like
there were massive failures at every
level in terms of security and the
administration at the school and all of
that stuff we'll find out more about
that what does justin trudeau do he uses
that tragedy as an excuse to take more
political power which by the way is
happening right here in the united
states we'll get to that in just a
second
and that's what i was referencing
earlier they don't do it all at once
it's too obvious if they come for your
rights all at once so they push and they
push and they wait and they see how far
they can push you etc etc we've played
this clip many times but i think it's
just apropos of everything we're talking
about uh one more time here's jordan
peterson this is on joe rogan a couple
months back i just don't understand how
it gets to the point where things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if i encroach if i encroach on
you and i'm sophisticated about it i'm
going to encroach two millimeters i'm
going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then i'm
going to stop then i'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then i'm
going to encroach again
right to the point where you protest
then i'm going to stop then i'm going to
wait and i'm just going to do that
forever and before you know it you're
going to be back three miles from where
you started and you'll have done it one
step at a time and then you'll go oh
how'd i get here and the answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed
you see what we're laying out here guys
i think we're making a case right so
what has justin trudeau done in canada
over the last couple years well
lockdowns vaccinations forcing people
out of work all that stuff so they
pushed a certain degree which we all got
pushed to that degree in the west right
then he goes okay now protesting will be
illegal right we're going to stop these
truckers these people who are only
protesting for their right to speak
freely their right to stand up against
their government their right to live as
they see fit we're going to make that
illegal too right because that's exactly
what he did and then what was it after
that oh we're going to freeze their bank
account so it's this move you keep
pushing you keep pushing and you wait a
little bit and you push and you push a
little bit more and after frozen bank
accounts what is it now well now we're
going to come for their guns
so you don't do it all at once this is
how governments work well i can't say
this how governments work this is how
bad authoritarian governments work this
isn't how western governments are
supposed to work but this apparently is
how the canadian government works and uh
if you're in canada and you're watching
this you got to think about what to do
you got to think about what to do i'm
telling you i'm meeting a lot of
canadians here in florida these days who
are trying to get the hell out and and
it makes sense where if this is the
direction that canada is going in what
will canada look like
in five years